the most ridiculous and arguably best
devil fruit in the series of One Piece
has been awakened by Luffy our
protagonist and he has dubbed this
Awakening gear 5 and said it was nothing
less than his peak in this video I'm
going to be explaining in detail this
awakened gear 5 and all of its powers
and how strong Luffy is with it so make
sure to stay tuned for that channel
parking with it and smash that like
button if you enjoy seeing one piece
videos like this one I want to keep them
coming don't forget to make sure you've
joined and not come up by subscribing
and hit that notification Bell so you
don't miss future one piece videos and
updates and now without further Ado
let's jump into the hypest Awakening the
final gear that let rubber David beat
Dragon Goliath so gear 5 is teased at
the end of chapter 1043 where we see a
Luffy that should be out of commission
smile and the top of his face looks like
it's melting we're even told by zunesha
that Joy boy has returned adding even
more significance to this Awakening and
fruit during chapter 1 1044 we learn
more thank you to the elders for
shedding some light on the sun god at
marijua it's asked and I quote so we've
lost an elite agent and made kaido Angry
what was the point end quote and then
Saturn the one who is currently coming
with kizaru to attack Egghead says what
if I told you that there was a potential
future that would make us beg for this
outcome it is always better to eliminate
dangerous variables clearly he
understands the threat here so I like
how Oda made him accompany kizaru to
stop vegapunk and now Luffy then another
Elder says in every era the world
government has attempted to recover the
gum gum fruit and not once has it ever
succeeded for 800 years it is as though
the devil fruit is trying to escape our
grasp and it very well might be zoned
fruits contain a will of their own and
this particular fruit has the name of a
God the other name of the gum gum fruit
is the Zone type human human fruit
mythical model Nika end quote so a lot
to unwrap there obviously the big reveal
that the government me is not a
paramecia but actually a mythical zone
is huge in and of itself then there's
the fact that zones have a will of their
own and can even invade the world
government the way I take this is not
that the Zone takes over the personality
of the user with its own but rather that
it seeks out compatible people with
already similar wills it would explain
why the Inu Inu no me model okuchi no
makami ended up going to Yamato despite
being in kaido's control because Yamato
wanted to protect wano and obviously so
did the wolf God mythical Zone which is
said to be the guardian deity of wano it
also explains why after the conflict
Yamato stays because why would a
guardian deity of wano pick someone who
would leave and not stay where they can
continue to protect wano this also
explains why as we're about to see Luffy
is still Luffy after Awakening and it's
not one of those I'm not Luffy on the
sun god Nika situations and thank God
for that we then see a silhouette of
Luffy's new form in the sky as the other
others continue to explain and I quote
possessing a body with the properties of
rubber and fighting in whatever way he
fancies bringing smiles to the faces of
the people the worry of Liberation also
known as Nika the sun god Awakening
brings his rubbery body greater physical
strength and freedom it is said that in
all the world there is no power more
ridiculous end quote so we got even more
to unpack here the fruit is associated
with the body possessing the properties
of rubber which explains why the
government wanted to hide the truth and
decided to do it by lying and saying
it's just a rubber paramecia fruit this
is the only instance of name changing we
know of but it does open the Gateway for
perhaps other fruits to be mislabeled
I'm personally looking at you Blackbeard
in your Darkness God fruit anyways next
we're told that the mythical zone is a
warrior of Liberation makes sense for
someone like Luffy who loves freedom and
ends up freeing people wherever he goes
and like it says here he also puts
smiles on people's faces so I know it's
not super relevant but man doesn't this
just make the elders look like the worst
like they want to unironically destroy a
guy who brings freedom and smiles
wherever he goes like they won't even
try to frame it like they're not the bad
guys here that's just something that
stood out to me we're informed that
Luffy's body will get power and freedom
boosts AKA his fists will pack more
punch and his body will be to put it
mildly impossibly flexible and adaptable
but more importantly that it is the most
ridiculous power in the world and that
it can let the fighter fight in whatever
way he fancies now that's the legend at
least but if true that means Luffy can
do anything even the impossible he's
only limited by his imagination now the
phrasing most ridiculous power might
want to make us jump to the conclusion
that this means he has the strongest
best fruit and that wouldn't be a
surprise for a god fruit that the
government fears more than any other
clearly but there is also the
possibility that they just mean the most
absurd power and another fruit May well
hold the other titles but either way as
we'll get into the power and Mastery of
hockey more than devil fruits determines
the strongest so I don't think we need
to get bogged down by what's the
strongest devil fruit since it depends
so much on the user anyways back to
awake and Luffy for now and he says ooh
I can do everything I wanted to do I
think I can fight a bit longer my
heartbeat sounds so funny this is the
Pinnacle of what I can do this is gear 5
end quote now tell me honestly in the
comments are there any words more hype
gear 5 was hyped up for so long and I
gotta say Oda really delivered here then
we finally stop hearing about the
Awakening and we start seeing what gear
5 can do against kaido even before he
grabs kaido's giant dragon form like
it's a snake toy multiple Beast Pirates
start fainting because of the conquerors
hockey coming off of Luffy in this form
so already we see that in this form
Luffy can make his fist big enough to
wrap around kaido's giant dragon body he
then Has the strength to pull him up
like he really is dealing with a snake
toy he does a Popeye Flex to show how
strong he is and then spins the before
god-like terrifying looking mythical
Zone making him look like he's in a
cartoon kaido's eyes popping out and
everything Luffy smashes kaido into the
ground over and over again and before
this form it was definitely hard to
picture anyone doing something like this
to kaido's gigantic Dragon form then we
see something very interesting kaido
launches a blast breath at Luffy and
Luffy shows he can manipulate his
surroundings he turns the ground into
Rubber and then lifts it up to bounce
kaido's blast breath back at him some
people in the comments think that this
makes Luffy's fruit a paramecia and
mythical Zone but let's remember that
Marco's mythical Zone also has
logia-like properties but that doesn't
make it a logia so I think it's the same
thing here Luffy's fruit is in fact a
mythical Zone and some of the aspects of
its Awakening like being able to affect
his surroundings happens to be similar
to a paramecium Awakening that's the
cool thing about mythical zones in
particular and why they're the best in
my opinion they have multiple abilities
and they can be similar to any fruit
type and even multiple fruit types
depending on the myth in question kaido
himself gets confused because of all
this saying given that you're
transferring your powers to other things
I suppose I can interpret this as The
Awakening of your paramecia powers but
something doesn't add up body
Transformations like that are the
trademark of Zone Powers the Fight
Continues and Luffy continues to do
crazy and pretty much impossible things
like it's Looney Tunes I've also heard
this multiple times referred to as Tune
Force AKA an ability that allows cartoon
characters to bypass laws of nature in
order to achieve impossible Feats for
comedic effects kaido swallows Luffy but
Luffy just keeps beating up kaido from
the inside first through zigzag patterns
and then by ballooning up to a
ridiculous degree and then kaido asks
what's wrong with me my body isn't made
of rubber so Luffy's Powers now let him
not only manipulate inanimate objects at
himself but other characters as well
absolutely insane stuff then Luffy sees
two lights that happen to be kaido's
eyes and in the most ridiculous move to
date he puts his hands through them and
grabs kaido's nose while kaido's
eyeballs stretch with Luffy's arms
creating some kind of weird dragon eye
gloves finally kaido expels Luffy from
his body since trying to eat him is
clearly not gonna work and if you notice
here's another interesting aspect to
Luffy's Powers they might actually be
helping his opponent in certain
situations think about it Luffy could
have torn through kaido's eyes if they
weren't so stretchy and that obviously
would have been a devastating blow I
totally agree that that would have been
anticlimactic and wouldn't have felt
like one piece at all but just something
that crossed my mind either way it looks
like Luffy is trying to have fun with
this fight and so it's arguable that he
wasn't even trying to finish it off
there Luffy then makes himself an
absolute giant that even Towers over
kaido's dragon head in the panel it's
crazy how easy it is for him to do
something like that in this form he then
proceeds to embarrass the living young
Uncle with the highest Bounty by using
him in his big bad Dragon form as get
this a jump rope Luffy then takes the
full brunt of a blast breath and he
looks comedically like he just got
barbecued but he quickly reverts to his
normal gear 5 appearance and proceeds to
fly by running through the air leaving a
trail of fire no less kaido now in his
hybrid form lands one of the most
epically named attacks in one piece
conqueror of three worlds ragnaraku and
Luffy's giant head comedically stretches
breaking through the roof and scaring
the Beast Pirates below his tuned Force
Powers seem to be overflowing and
affecting those around him as even
people like law and kid have their eyes
pop out in cartoonish fashion I really
look forward to seeing how this part
will be animated in the anime and how
cartoonish they will make it then all of
a sudden kaido says Luffy has reached
his limit and accordingly Luffy's face
starts drooping so he looks like an old
man and his hair has turned black again
he had admits he's all tuckered out
nevertheless Luffy says this can't end
yet and re-enters his gear 5 form kaido
says careful or you'll die and Luffy
says you actually think I'm afraid of
that Luffy says come on heart hit that
beat and then he is back to being full
of energy as he says yeah that's the
sound so we see here that even when
tuckered out Luffy in this form can use
his heartbeat to keep fighting now I
won't enter the long-term consequences
of this for the time being since it
would just be speculation at this point
but it's pretty crazy for now at least
that he can just refuel himself like
that by telling his heart to beat in a
specific way then we see the insane
growth of Luffy's stretchiness in this
form kaidu hits him with his Spike club
for Luffy blunt things weren't a problem
but sharp things were now though his
face impossibly wraps around the spikes
and there doesn't even seem to be a
pinch of blood to signify the
penetration of the skin by the spikes
obviously a sword could still be a
different story compared to spikes but
Luffy has potentially come a long way to
overcoming a big weakness in this form
kairo then smashes Luffy into the ground
but Luffy dampens the effect of the hit
by not only stretching his own body to
ridiculous degrees but also by making
the ground beneath him like a sort of
trampoline as you can imagine that would
really dampen the force of even the
hardest swing as Luffy spins his fist
around like a helicopter kaido wonders
what does all of this mean he says Luffy
turns all white he uses the colors of
armament and the Supreme King and can
transfer his powers to other things I've
never seen such free wheel in combat
before end quote Kairos has allowed
there's no one in the world who can
defeat him but just then it looks like
Luffy's fist goes straight through
kaido's head another thing that if it
happened without Tune Force should end
someone but kaido's head is intact
afterwards it is made clear though that
there's hockey infused with Luffy's
punches and so it nonetheless hurt kaido
a lot Luffy then asks kaido isn't this
fun showing he's having a blast in
himself we then again get zunesha
recognizing Luffy's Rhythm the Rhythm
that came with Awakening as that of Joy
Boys he says he can feel that fate is at
work so again it asks us to remember
that this fruit is tied to the old Joy
boy and that it's tied to the prophecy
the one Roger was too early for Luffy is
the New Joy boy that has been
prophesized now yes I know a lot of
people don't like stuff being fated to
be but nonetheless it's important to
note in a discussion of this fruit the
fruit seems to be wrapped up in the fate
of the world and thus so is Luffy by
extension it's probably why the
government fears it more than any other
fruit as well but don't worry Oda
balances this later on as we'll see and
now back to the fight where Luffy again
tells kaido that he'll surpass him and
become the king of the pirates kaido for
his part is glad Luffy still has SASS
and says Awakening is what happens when
your mind and body catch up to your
powers and those are certainly
ridiculous Powers unquote on a side note
doesn't that make kaido sound like an
expert on awakening and like he has
awakened himself just some food for
thought then Luffy launches many quick
punches which again stretch kaido's body
to a ridiculous degree kaido launches
razor sharp air blades at Luffy and the
dude pulls up the lower half of his body
so his legs stretch and the blades go
between his legs without even touching
him Luffy continues to do crazy thing
after crazy thing he catches a lightning
bolt and like Zeus himself he launches
it at kaido calling the move gum gum
lightning dude thinks he's a nil now
kaido Dodges lands a hit on Luffy and
then Luffy uses another lightning bolt
like a pole to catch himself and spin
around he uses it to propel himself and
attack kaido only for kaido to smash him
in the face with a spike Club kaido says
abilities alone cannot conquer the world
the world is convenient that way Roger
didn't have any food Powers because only
hockey can transcend all end quote and
there is the rub I've been talking about
Oda was wants to make it clear yeah
Luffy's fruit power is the most
ridiculous but without hockey Mastery
even the best fruit power isn't a big
deal in fact the one who was pirate king
and conquered the world so to speak
before didn't have any devil fruit so
it's oda's way of telling us yeah I know
I gave Luffy a super special fruit but
that doesn't mean Luffy is automatically
the strongest because of it no haki is
more important and Luffy can still
improve in that regard even if gear 5
really is his final form and his Peak
when it comes to the devil fruit as
Luffy says it is the only problem for
kaido is as we're about to see Luffy is
no slouch when it comes to hockey
Mastery either for now kaido hits Luffy
and Sons and flying Luffy grabs onto
kaido's skin like he's wearing a shirt
another Tune Force detail kaido wants
Luffy to let go of him but Luffy doesn't
kairo tries to free himself with a spike
Club but it doesn't work and then he
assumes that Luffy still has a weakness
to cutting attacks and sends more air
blades at him in his Dragon form and
some do make Luffy bleed but he's still
holding on kaido launches a blast breath
and again Luffy looks barbecued but he
still holds on he finally says I'm gonna
put an end to all of this as his giant
fist comes from the clouds and the fist
is so big it even makes it look like
kaido's giant dragon form could be
squished by this all-powerful fist that
fist can even destroy onigashima that's
how unbelievably big it is this is when
kaido uses his secret technique flame
dragon torch his whole body is set
Ablaze making him all the bigger kaido
says Luffy's fist will melt before it
touches him Luffy explains that the old
man taught him to do that without
touching referring to Advanced hockey
AKA real he says he'll smash kaido all
the way down to the bottom of Hell the
two enter the final clash as Luffy says
he'll create a world where his friends
can eat as much as they want his hockey
breaks through and kaido is sent flying
deep into the Earth now as usual after
an epic fight and as expected after
beating the so-called strongest creature
in the world with the highest active
yonko Bounty Luffy is exhausted and
faints and Yamato is there to catch him
nevertheless Luffy did it he beat the
living yonko with the highest Bounty
what an epic way to show his Yoko level
now and he used his awakened fruit to do
it but azoda made clear it was his
Mastery over hockey that let him
ultimately come out with the win not
just the Awakening so at this point you
might be thinking what are the
consequences of using such an
overpowered ridiculous form Well for now
at least doesn't look like there are
much in a couple of chapters Luffy is
conscious again and excited about eating
meat the elders are then Furious when
they see that Luffy's new Bounty poster
has been printed with his gear 5
awakened appearance and try their best
to keep the posters from going out into
the world further showing how much they
feared the sun god fruit and the myth of
the Sun God is that he's seen as a
savior one who will bring the oppressed
Liberty from the oppressor and it's
understandable why a group that's
focused on controlling the world would
be so worried about a figure that might
be used as an inspirational symbol one
who might encourage more to rise up and
seek Liberation that would definitely
mean a lot of headaches for the world
government and maybe the eventual
toppling of the world government and
what I think is a further strategy to
take attention away from Luffy is that
they lowballed his Bounty big time they
made it seem like Luffy kid and law as
equal Partners took down kaido and big
mom and they all get 3 billion very
bounties apiece accordingly this is
ridiculous and clearly Luffy should get
a higher Bounty bigger than kaido's for
being the one to bring down kaido while
kid and law worked together to bring
down big mom who had a lower Bounty than
kaido to begin with but at least Luffy
is then proclaimed as one of the four
yonko now and buggy joins him but that's
the topic for an entirely different
video the important thing is awaken
Luffy is now seen on the same level as
Shanks the man who inspired him to be a
pirate in the first place a pretty epic
development and speaking of Shanks he's
relevant for this video because we know
when ayak was associated with a devil
fruit it's very special indeed
Blackbeard spent his whole life
searching for the yamiyami no me until
he got it kaido wanted and found the
mythical Zone wolf God fruit because he
wanted to take over wano and it's the
guardian deity of wano so with that in
mind we can bet that Shanks understood
the significance of the gomugomonomi
when he brought it to Luffy's Village he
knew Roger and he probably knew more
about the prophecy and the sun god than
most so the fact that of all fruits he
was watching over that one shows that it
wasn't these special from the beginning
and it adds another reason why Shanks
would be willing to sacrifice his arm
for Luffy the now user of that special
fruit he sacrificed it to use his own
words for the sake of the new era and
from what we can gather according to
prophecy the awakened sun god fruit user
AKA Joy boy is a key figure in that new
era that Roger was too early for now
let's jump to chapter 1069 where Rob
Lucia Reveals His awakened leopard fruit
and faces off against gear 5 Luffy
thankfully unlike Goku with ultra
Instinct initially Luffy doesn't have an
issue with entering gear 5 when he wants
to many theorize that that might be the
case before he used it against Luchi
when vegapunk sees this form he says
tell me what is this transformation when
he's told isn't it me the smartest dude
in the world says even in the oldest
books there is no such thing as a gum
gum fruit keep in mind even though we
know our crew still doesn't know about
the gum gum fruit being the sun god Nika
fruit Vega punk calls Luffy a beautiful
sight saying he looks just like a god he
expands saying the foolish and laughable
worry of Liberation who brings smiles to
all people also known as Nika the Sun
God he explains it's a name that's been
erased from the historical record but as
long as people wish for him his
existence will never truly disappear all
things are brought into this world with
hope even the devil fruits end quote the
implication of course is that people
wish for someone who will liberate them
and probably always will and if they do
the sun god Nika fruit will never cease
to exist vegapunk further explains that
every devil fruit is a possibility for
human evolution that someone desired if
only I could be like this if only I
could be like that all of those Powers
represent the many branches of the
future of humanity but that unnatural
state is loathed by the seed the mother
of nature A fitting punishment for its
sin those with powers exist in different
dimensions dreamed up by someone else
before them end quote he adds it is just
his theory but it's a big info bomb
about something present since the
beginning of one piece and I find the
line about the many branches of the
future of humanity very intriguing it
also suggests that Liberation is one
potential path and darkness is another
and even if the clash between freedom
and the dawn represented by Luffy and
darkness represented by Blackbeard is
faded perhaps the conclusion is yet to
be determined so that adds some more
intensity to their final inevitable
Clash anyways we see Luffy moving his
head and stretching his neck to avoid
luchi's attacks and then clashing hockey
infused fists with him at this point I
and I hope many of the fan base knew
that Luchi was no match for Luffy but we
were excited to see more of Luffy's fun
new powers we saw Luffy use gum gum mole
pistol where he punched into the ground
and like a mole it went through the
ground and popped up near Luchi to
deliver a devastating hit Luffy during
this fight also twists himself up to
deliver a gum gum Dawn whip that sends
Luchi flying while Luffy himself can't
stop spinning later Luffy makes his head
so big that he tries to eat lushi but
Luchi moves out of the way Luffy then
uses a tube to propel himself delivering
a dawn rocket AKA devastating punch to
Luchi that stretches the ladder's body
to an insane level Lucci while in pain
can't help but ask himself where is he
getting so much force then when he's
done with the fighting Luffy reversed to
his old man's saggy form and him and his
people leave using the vacuum rocket now
Luffy does recover before too long and
is ready when they have to face the
seraphim with Luchi he takes on a
seraphim using gear 4 rather than gear
5. in the latest chapter 1089 we saw
that the straw hats and cp0 were
victorious they got the trader York by
her neck and Luchi is there uncuffed
suggesting that they trust him for now
which is crazy since we got the
government forces like kizuru and even
an elder coming Luffy looks in great
condition eating meat and it's not
obvious yet if he needed gear 5 at all
to overcome the seraphim so that's what
we saw from gear 5 so far it is the
awakened sun god Nika fruit and we saw
Luffy doing crazy seemingly impossible
things with it but it was also made
clear that fruits alone will never be
enough which in its own way makes up for
giving your protagonist and overpowered
God fruit most impressively Luffy used
this form to help beat kaido and more
recently he used it to help out class
Rob Luchi a feat not that impressive
after kaido but more interesting after
Lucio awakened his own fruit at least
we've yet to see Luffy reach his limit
AKA an opponent he can't overcome since
he awakened his devil fruit so now we
have to wait to see if anyone can still
topple the dude who toppled the
strongest creature in the world after
this video I hope you can see how
amazing and honestly better mythical
zones are better than every other fruit
category to be sure and with that in
mind you definitely won't want to miss
my recent video about all 12 mythical
Zone users explained and ranked link on
screen right now and I'll see you there